camille Grammer recently instagrammed a
beach photoshoot with her daughter mason
captioned proud of my scars no
retouching yeah researching et caught up
with the pair at New York Fashion Week
before Mason hit the runway
Camille shared how she's rebuilding her
confidence as a cancer survivor I'm in
remission
will be three years in January I had a
very aggressive form of cancer so you
know it's when I take these photographs
I you know at first I was embarrassed
with my scars but no I'm not it's part
of my what I've been through it's I've
survived it I'm a warrior and The Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills star is
getting back in shape after recovery
you know after you have a hysterectomy
you don't feel feminine it was very
important for me to feel feminine again
and because of the loss of hormones and
everything like that I felt insecure I
take dance classes to feel feminine and
I take it's a sexy dance class in Malibu
Netta Malibu jams trailer and she you
know brings out the feminine sexual
sides here again